i love sipping bourbon and sitting
around the comforting glow of my solo
stove i'm telling you isn't this the
greatest i've also had two of these
because i had to test it you didn't have
to test it i learned your words
it's like the way i say santa
live
i was going to take a low dosage edible
before i came here and i'm really glad i
did it remember we we went to dinner
once with a reporter and i fell asleep
at the dinner wait wait what okay freeze
what reporter why why did you fall
asleep was that our story was it was a
variety or variety or hollywood
no it was bright if it's not the
montebello paper no it was like a cover
story
it was it was a cover story and variety
uh back when such a thing was possible
and um was this the one they did for the
podcast mm-hmm no no before that this is
before that doesn't interest me no but
um
and sona
took an edible and this woman's talk and
sona's part of the story and then at one
point
sona's head goes down onto the shoulder
of the reporter oh
what
did she write about that and she was
lovely she was really lovely and so nice
she was very cool
but you just passed out
i just fell asleep like snore drooling
like the whole night
you're my hero i know oh and you know
there's another time this happened not
with sona but with uh tracy king shout
out for tracy king we were
traveling our show somewhere it was
always chaotic and then we would go and
have dinner we had just come back from
the theater and we were having dinner in
some city
i don't know if i've been everywhere
but anywho
um you've barely been to pasadena no you
complained about driving like 30 miles
so um
it's longer than that
it's the quality of the journey
so so tracy
king our producer extraordinaire joins
us at the table and she just we didn't
know this but she had
thought that she was maybe getting a
migraine so she took a pill for her
migraine yeah and but she accidentally
took
a sleeping pill oh i've done that and so
she was at the table and she started to
say things that didn't were kind of
slurry and then her face started to look
strange and i swear to god i thought she
was having a stroke oh my god and um
and all of us started to get worried
like chills you remember this jason
chalemi's here and his name is chills
that's and he's also
always around when there's a chill chum
that's i mean this is perfect do you
remember this chills
hold on stand next to that recording
device called the microphone it was in
san francisco yep and she took an
ambient by accident she took an ambient
by accident and then i think was having
some wine or something and it got bad
fast it got bad fast and we got scared
because i thought wait a minute what's
what are the signs of a stroke right um
but then we quickly
i think figured it out but she finally
went through our pills in her bag and it
was like a huge relief afterwards right
yeah and she had a pill that gives you a
stroke in her purse
which fortunately she didn't take i
don't know why she had that pill she had
she said i have a prescription for pills
that give you a stroke and i just like
to keep them in my purse ask your doctor
about strokes
stroke sam will give you a stroke
warning may cause strokes
warning 100 chances will give you stroke
warding may not cause a stroke
exactly